nvidia holds a giant conference deepmind
buys and open sources mojoco and google
predicts what you're gonna write in a
spreadsheet welcome to ml news
hello hello this video is sponsored by
nvidia actually not just nvidia but they
want to raise awareness for their gtc
conference which happens november 8
through 11 this year now there is
something in it for you if you use my
link to register to this you can win a
30 90. so these gpus are super rare
nowadays and one is allocated just for
my link to register so you're not
competing with the rest of youtube
you're just competing with anyone that
uses my link so if you're interested use
the link in the description to register
to the conference now the conference is
actually relevant for machine learning
audience because nvidia is not only
talking about nvidia though i love the
what will jensen huang's keynote reveal
banner right here being super mysterious
and all okay nvidia says i should hype
up the keynote more so this keynote is
going to be the maddest keynote you've
ever seen you remember last keynote
where jensen huang was like rendered and
nvidia made this big deal about how they
rendered him and this was like a big
effort then they had to correct
themselves and state that it was
actually only for 14 seconds and not for
the entire keynote because that's kind
of what they alluded to at the beginning
i reported about this in ml news it was
epic and i guess this keynote is going
to be epic again will he finally reveal
what the leather jacket is made of if
you haven't seen yet on twitter if you
use the hashtag gtc21
it actually renders a little leather
jacket next to it and i think nvidia
paid for this like isn't this the
greatest marketing like business
decision by twitter they're able to sell
hashtags
insane and uh i don't know what's gonna
happen but i've come across this the
omniverse which is in beta and there's
kind of speculation that that's going to
be one of the topics i didn't know this
existed this is sort of like a real time
rendering framework that's that's based
on pixar's universal scene description
and nvidia rtx
and it's pretty insane so apparently
this is this real time this is an entire
framework where you can do like
real-time ray tracing
look at this this looks great
i don't know how many rtx's you need for
that one but it's pretty insane this
used to take like insane amounts of
rendering time and
yeah the fact that it's real time really
cool but they have invited a bunch of
speakers to talk about all kinds of
stuff in graphics in machine learning
and in many other areas of computation
so they really want this to be a big
thing this conference and you can see
this these are just some of the speakers
you can see fei feli is speaking uh ilia
sami and many others that you might know
of so these are three pages of speakers
that are really big in their industry
nvidia is spending a ton of cash right
here to give you essentially free
content now you do need to register to
watch all of these talks but it's free
and as i said you can win a 30 90. now
before we go on i would like to say that
the condition for the sponsorship of
nvidia was that the video must be
available in english and in german which
is weird you know but since i speak
german i can do that so this video is
available as a not a copy but an
equivalent in a german version so if
this is not the language you expected
switch over to the other video and i
promise i'll just put on my absolute
best impression of a real german so a
little bit more about this conference
while the keynote is obviously the main
event right here nvidia revealing what
they're gonna do which given nvidia's
size and dominance is quite relevant for
the entire deep learning world there are
over 500 sessions if you look at the
schedule there are 15 sessions just
dedicated to pytorch and 12 dedicated to
tensorflow and those aren't the only
deep learning sessions there are many
many more as you can see there is a
plethora of industry types and topics
that people are gonna talk about it's
like an endless list so rest assured
that during these four days you can just
bathe in nvidia content for 24 hours a
day now along with the conference there
are these instructor-led workshops that
give you hands-on experience in certain
things for example building
transformer-based natural language
processing applications they do cost a
little bit of money but they're hands-on
so if you're interested in that take a
look so i don't know what more to say as
i said it's completely free content
they're throwing a bunch of money to get
really good speakers and you can win a
graphics card and look at them frame
numbers we all know more frames means
that you're a better gamer so get the
3090 now link is in the description
check out all the talks and the sessions
that happen at the conference and i wish
you a really pleasant experience nvidia
is really trying to gear up this
conference to make it a big deal and as
it seems it is actually a big deal next
news
[Music]
deepmind has apparently bought mojo co
which is one of the primary simulation
softwares for robotics this has been
used again and again not only in
robotics but also in deep learning in
reinforcement learning in all these
kinds of settings to do continuous
control simulations as you can see here
this uh works pretty well this is a real
flipping flippity spinidy spin and here
you see one in mujo co now the trouble
with mujyoko has always been that it was
proprietary and not only that not only
was it not open source but you had to
pay quite a bit of money for it so now
apparently deepmind has bought and open
sourced mujo co replication efforts have
been underway but very often these
simulators they are built for gaming or
something like this and they neglect
effects such as these gyroscopic effects
right here which you can see that mojoco
apparently has a good balance between
realism and accuracy for these kinds of
simulations and not only that but it is
also fast enough so you can do
reinforcement learning with it and
deepmind has used this extensively this
is all apparently from deepmind's works
you can see how versatile the simulator
is so now deepmind has bought it and
makes it available to everyone which is
pretty pretty cool now is this really
out of kindheartedness maybe actually
maybe they just want to get some good pr
out there or maybe they want to do
another nature publication and nature
publications do force you i believe to
open source pretty much anything that
you have to achieve the publications
whatever it might be it's pretty cool
that deepmind does it the code base is
apparently in c so it's portable
compilable pretty much anywhere yeah
give it a try looking forward to playing
around with this
pytorch releases release 1.10 this
brings a number of improvements such as
the inclusion of the cuda graphs api now
kudo graphs is an api it's not for
machine learning on graphs not for graph
neural networks but it is for defining
graphs of operations over cuda kernels
in this case here every letter is a cuda
kernel such as a matrix multiplication
or an addition of two things and you
used to have to put one cpu instruction
for each one of the cuda kernels so the
cpu had to say now you do a matrix
multiplication now you add two things
and so on now the kudo graphs api
enables you to with a single cpu
instructions instruct the gpu to perform
an entire graph of operations and this
is now available in pytorch and not only
that they have a few other things
notably the torch.special
module which replicates scipy.special so
if you've used these functions in numpy
in scipy now they're available in torch
and there are some more such as the
nnmodule parameterization this enables
you that for example if you want to
change the normalization function in a
module you used to have to re-implement
the module to sub-class it and
essentially re-implement it while
replacing the normalization itself and
now apparently you can simply from the
outside say i want to change the
normalization i want to change different
things inside of a module so it makes
pytorch code more friendly towards
experimentation towards swapping out
individual parts there are a bunch of
other different new things in pytorch
110 but it seems to be cool release if
you can upgrade give it a try
google has a new blog post and along
with a paper the paper is called
spreadsheet coder formula prediction
from semi-structured context this is a
cool paper because it helps you to write
formulas in spreadsheets now google
spreadsheets is a pretty big project and
this feature is now available to anyone
using google spreadsheets so what it's
going to do is it's going to essentially
bring the tab complete that you might be
used to from gmail or from google docs
into the formula section of a
spreadsheet so as soon as you type the
equal symbol it's going to try to
predict what formula you're trying to
write it takes into consideration the
values of the things around you takes
into consideration what you called the
headers and the row headers so for
example here the row is called total and
therefore it might be reasonable to
assume that you want the sum of the
column above whereas over here you
called the header percent chain so the
system infers that you probably given
that you have no values above as well
that you probably want to do something
with the totals of the other two columns
this is not hard-coded this is all
learned from a big corpus and this is as
i said now available for anyone using
google spreadsheets so the system seems
to be a quite of an engineering effort
so they have a row-based bird encoder
column-based bird encoder they have
convolutions in there they aggregate and
then they decode using an lstm i guess
this had to go through a bunch of
iterations before they got really nicely
working system but now it actually made
it into a product and this is something
that we see rarely nowadays that
research to product is actually
happening so pretty cool and benefits
anyone that uses google spreadsheets
they also do a lot of ablations and you
can see that in their tests for various
length of context and things they want
to predict they do reach a pretty decent
accuracy so almost 50 accuracy in
formulas you you might want to write now
i don't know what 50 accuracy actually
means because most people just want like
the sum or the mean of anything but
nonetheless it's a pretty cool
development if you want to check out
more check out the spreadsheet coder
paper try it out
a cool project that i saw on reddit is
hand tracking dot io this is a
completely in-browser hand tracking demo
and this focuses around detecting
special poses that your hand does for
example detecting when you pinch your
fingers or when you make a fist and then
mapping those things to various actions
you can actually try this out so this
fully runs in your browser as you can
see it tracks my hand if i make a fist
the screen clears
and if i pinch my fingers it doesn't
work all too well maybe it's because i
have a green screen or anything else
maybe it works above my it does not too
well
but
you can see
if you go slowly
yeah this is pretty cool so um this is
mit licensed it's available on github
and uh
up for you to check it out or simply try
it in this browser it's up to you what
you do with it pretty cool
cable has a new challenge on cell
instance segmentation now this is a
challenging task you get a bunch of
microscopy images and your task is to
segment single instances of of cells so
neurons in tissue and you need to detect
where they are apparently this is a hard
task that is as of yet pretty weakly
solved and this challenge is supposed to
get us there faster if you want to do
something cool with computer vision that
also has a direct application in
medicine this challenge might be for you
okay some helpful libraries and things
that i've encountered this week control
flag by intellabs is a library that will
detect source code mistakes or
anti-patterns or bugs or anything like
this so this is a self-supervised system
it learns by itself it's essentially a
big language model or a pattern model
that recognizes common patterns in code
bases and then is able to recognize when
a given pattern is uncommon therefore if
you write something that's probably a
bug then it will detect it as an
uncommon pattern and notify you to it
this is more than just bugs so this is
not specifically trained on a supervised
data set where someone says here's a bug
here's not a bug this is as i said a
self-supervised system that is specific
to source code and right now it actually
works in c and i believe also in very
log but it's a matter of time before
someone takes this and expands this to
new languages and trains it on new
languages so the source code for the
source code checker is available on
github you can try it out you can train
it in fact yourself you can let it run
over your own code base the only issue
is that if you write a bug that lots of
other people write too it won't detect
it right because it's not an uncommon
pattern but you know that's that's life
i guess salina by facebook research is a
lightweight library for sequential
learning agents including reinforcement
learning so this is a library that is
supposed to make it really easy to write
very complex sequential models like
sequential decision making models where
you have to perform actions in a row in
some sort of sense the library is
purposefully very general but it's
fairly easy to write something like an
a2c agent you can see right here this is
the entire a2c agent right here but it's
not only for reinforcement learning it
is any kind of complex sequential
decision making process if you're
interested in that kind of research if
the rl libraries that are available just
didn't do it for you quite yet maybe
give selena a try speaking of sequences
why data synthetic is a generator
library for synthetic structured data so
this is a library that you can give data
to it will learn the data in some sort
of a generative fashion and it will be
able to give you synthetic data to work
with so this can be due to privacy
reasons it can be because you don't have
enough
of some data and you want to generate
more of it this can be because you
simply want to test on something that's
not real data so there are various
reasons why you do something like this
specifically this right here is for
tabular data and time series data which
are often data that is not that easy to
work with most of our things like gans
work on images we have some text
generators but having another library
available for tabular and time series
data is quite cool so if this is of
interest to you give y data synthetic a
try they have some easy examples for
example right here they want to train a
gan to produce one particular class of
their fraud data set you can see as the
training progresses the gan gets better
and better at modeling this light blue
data and you know presumably if you
train it for more it's gonna get even
better and then you have a generator for
data you don't need real data anymore
who needs data ah aim is an open source
uh ml platform so this is another
experiment tracker but it is work in
progress it's ongoing progress it's open
source it's raw if you're into things
like arch linux or writing your own
bootloader and things like this aim
might be a cool project for you the new
version specifically deals with scales
so they used to have problems when you
have lots and lots and lots of
experiments to track but now even this
is solved so it seems like a cool github
project a thing that you might even get
involved with and everything's available
on github as i said integrates with
common frameworks pretty easy to get
going with it as you can see there is a
roadmap with lots of things to do if you
have fun contributing to open source
maybe give aim a try and lastly robust
bench is a standardized benchmark for
adversarial robustness it is a benchmark
if you think you have an adversarial
defense or an attack then this is a
benchmark where you can simply plug it
in and see how it does versus various
things they also have 80 plus
state-of-the-art pre-trained robust
models via the model zoo so you can
attack models that have been robustified
i guess you can do that in white box
black box settings and so on if you're
into adversarial examples give robust
bench a try
this is some rather funny news cbs local
in san francisco writes or rather
reports that there is apparently a
street where waymo cars they keep coming
in hitting a dead end turning around and
then going out again
and this apparently happens every five
minutes the waymo cars as you can see
they have drivers but i think they are
testing the driver less systems
sometimes you can see the drivers they
manipulate the steering wheel so i'm not
sure what exactly happens neither are
they neither are the drivers apparently
so no one's exactly sure what they're
doing there apparently the drivers are
simply following the programming of the
car you see there's a hand on the
steering wheel so i'm not not entirely
sure what's going on but the
waymo is really really really exploring
this one particular dead end really hard
so safe to say there's probably some
sort of a routing issue going on here
where the cars are told to go this
particular way then the cars detect that
there's a dead end then they turn around
but they never somehow update the fact
that they cannot go through there it's
either this or they have like an
automated exploration system where they
think oh i haven't explored this part of
the city yet i need to go and map it and
every time they go there they realize
they can't go through something like
this must be happening i guess it's
pretty funny i'm looking forward to the
world of driverless cars where teenagers
simply cheese the cars
and see how many of them they can get
stuck in a single cul-de-sac or or dead
end or something like this good future
to look forward to
and lastly i saw this right here now
this is pretty pretty cool this is by a
company called blue river technology and
they are aiming to be sort of the the
boston dynamics of agriculture you can
see that their control systems
essentially they're the same control
systems that you're used to it just
looks absolutely spectacular when it's
built into some sort of an agricultural
machine like a tractor or anything like
this this is obviously just a demo they
have a full website that is as you can
see you full with corporate pictures and
corporate speech and so on but it seems
very cool that ai is coming to real
disciplines like agriculture it has a
real potential to do both good for the
environment because you might need to
use less fertilizers and so on if you
can put it more targeted and save a
bunch of money i don't know maybe it's a
terrible thing who who knows i don't but
i do see definitely a lot of potential
for ai in these domains nature plus
robots has never ever ever turned bad in
the history of anything you know
something to look forward to and uh
everyone's smiling of course everyone's
just chilling around smiling
that that is that is a company that is
you need to go work there
all right that was it for ml news this
week i hope you enjoyed again thanks to
nvidia for sponsoring this video
register to gtc using the link winner 30
90 sleep well
exercise eat good food and i'll see you
next time bye
[Music]
you